y = negative one-half x + 8.
When an equation has
more than one variable,
you can solve that equation for
one of the variables.
Remember that a variable
represents a number.
So you can do the same operations on
variable terms, so add, subtract,
multiply and divide,
that you can do to numbers.
Let's look at the steps to solve for y.
And remember that when solving for
a variable, we're trying to get that
variable alone on one side of
the equation with a coefficient of 1.
I'm going to subtract 2x to move the 2x
to the other side of the equation.
And I get 4y + 0 = 32- 2x.
Or just 4y = 32- 2x.
I want the coefficient in
front of the y to be 1.
So let's divide it by 4 and
then we get y = 32- 2x all over 4.
We can simplify this, 32 / 4 is 8,
and 2x / 4 is one-half x.
By convention, terms with variables
will go before constants.
So this is actually negative one-half
x + 8, but both are correct.